if light doesn't have rust mass why
can't it escape a black hole because
nothing escapes a black hole
then how does gravity escape a black
hole it doesn't
what about hawking radiation nothing
escapes a black hole
[Music]
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies there are a lot of
misconceptions about black holes out
there
let's see if we can fix a few we'll
start with the one i hear the most
the escape velocity at the event horizon
is the speed of light
wrong that gives you the impression that
if you could somehow travel faster than
light you could escape a black hole
which simply isn't true
what's escape velocity a concept
entirely in the realm of classical
physics
say you've got a squirrel you want to
launch into space with one momentary
burst of acceleration
what upward speed is required for it to
escape earth's gravitational pull
that's the escape velocity emphasis on
the word
momentary a rocket doesn't work like
this
a rocket has continuous thrust which
isn't what we're talking about
instead we mean boom suddenly the
squirrel is going really fast
fast fast after that it's only affected
by gravity
or even ignoring the surrounding air
[Music]
keep forgetting about that anyway how
fast does this thing need to go to
escape
well considering the energy
transformation it comes out to be this
g is a constant these two are the mass
and radius of the earth
or whatever you're launching from mars
the moon
whatever it seems pretty natural to take
a concept like this to the extreme
there should be some choice of r such
that the resulting speed
is the speed of light except this would
be wrong it's wrong
because we wouldn't be considering
relativity while newton's laws apply to
99
of the things in 99 of the universe
black holes and the speed of
light are distinctly not those things
they're in the other one percent of one
percent
when you take physics to the extremes
you have to use extreme models
the friendly simple ones just don't work
anymore we need to use general
relativity
which says gravity isn't really pulling
anything
no there isn't an invisible hand
reaching out and grabbing things
no there isn't any transmission of
information telling things what to do
no space itself is not falling inward
according to general relativity gravity
is the curvature of space time
gravity is geometry you might be
picturing something like this
stop that right now space isn't
two-dimensional
it's three-dimensional so it looks more
like this although that still ignores
time which we really shouldn't do the
space-time geometry
around any non-rotating spherical object
is described by something called the
swarshield metric
omg i actually said it right that time
this tells us how far apart nearby
events are
in time and space you can see that
depends on how close you are to the
source of curvature
is it okay for the r to be in the
denominator like that
nope no it isn't when denominators go to
zero in a model
we call that a singularity and if you're
paying attention
there are actually two of them in there
if all the mass is compressed into a
single point
we get what's called a physical
singularity at r equals zero but there's
also this negative exponent which means
this term flips over
and we run into another problem at the
schwarzschild radius
otherwise known as the radius of the
event horizon
yes the event horizon is a second
singularity for the black hole
we call it a coordinate singularity
because you can remove it with a change
in coordinates
bottom line though a distant observer
sees a problem at the event horizon
but someone falling into the black hole
does not i did a whole video about this
a while back
wait isn't this war shield radius the
same as no no
it only looks the same but just let me
explain
here's what we got earlier for an escape
velocity at the speed of light
and here's the swarshield radius yes
they look the same
but that's just a coincidence while
those results are the same
they were derived using completely
different models which means they mean
different things
an event horizon has nothing to do with
escape velocity
an event horizon is about causality it's
about time
what happens as something falls into a
black hole is difficult to understand
at least until we add a time axis the
squirrel's path through space time
would normally be straight upward
through time this
region represents all possible futures
the squirrel could have
the edges of which are the paths taken
by light signals it might send
but because of the black hole the
squirrel's actual future is curved
as it falls in more and more of its
future points toward the black hole
it isn't being pulled in it just goes in
because that's where its future goes
this is taken to the extreme at the
event horizon before the squirrel
crosses the horizon
there are still some possible futures
that would allow it to escape
it would just have to accelerate really
hard
once it crosses though all of its
possible futures point inward
even if it tries to send signals those
will also go
inward no matter the direction it's a
trap
once you're inside there's no such thing
as outward
it's like that house from warehouse 13
where if you try to leave
you're just still inside the house
scoring that an 8.5 next time you gotta
stick the landing so how does the
gravity get out it doesn't
have you even listening gravity is just
what we
call it when space and time are curved
it doesn't have to escape
because that geometry is already on the
outside
you're only trapped if you end up inside
the event horizon
and the reason you're trapped is because
all your possible futures point inward
it's not that you can't escape it's
simply that you won't escape
black holes don't capture objects they
don't capture light
black holes capture the future
whoa dude so was this clear enough for
everyone
let us know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us until next time
remember
it's okay to be a little crazy
the most common question from the last
video was what is momentum space
it's just a visual way to represent the
random quantum motions of the neutrons
inside the neutron star don't overthink
it anyway thanks for watching